camouflage is important in the oceans  it's a cutthroat world outside these  submarine walls  today we're talking about sea horses and  their ability to camouflage  my grandfather jacques cousteau always  stood out in a crowd because of his  style these seahorses do just the  opposite  seahorses are masters of camouflage  the pygmy seahorse is one of the most  well camouflaged species in the ocean  and the smallest variety of seahorses  that exist  they're the size of a paperclip  in fact the pygmy seahorse wasn't  discovered until someone was examining a  piece of coral it was on  seahorses much like chameleons can  change color they change color to  confuse predators as well as to convey  emotions to one another especially  during courtship  the speed at which they change color  depends on what's happening as a  response to fear it's rapid whereas if  it's due to hormonal changes it's much  slower  it's gone  what do you mean it's gone  no  no no it's right there  stealthy seahorse